the things you notice about children
for example is if children don't get
enough good attention they'll certainly
go after bad attention because the
fundamental human currency is a tension
and it's it's one thing to be hated but
it's another thing entirely to be
ignored and i would say generally
speaking if you put people in a corner
and you made them choose you know if
they were if they had knowledge that was
transparent to themselves said well
would you rather be ignored or hated
they'd take hate it because at least
then you exist because you exist at
least in some part in your relationship
to other people and so some of the bad
behavior is is rewarded precisely for
that reason is that it does draw
attention and that does make you signify
all right hey everybody it is may 26
2022 i'm dave rubin this is the reuben
report direct message we are live
streaming as always on rumble blaze tv
and youtube do me a solid and subscribe
uh i thought that was the right video to
use today as are called open because you
know yesterday the way i did the show
was no elements no pics no video none of
that just kind of raw from my heart
what's going on in the world right now
and when i spent a little bit of time on
social media yesterday and the day
before as the uvalde shooting was
breaking news
it was just horrible it was horrible
across the board it was it was endlessly
political it was people trying to
destroy each other own each other do
whatever they could for retweets and for
clicks and the rest of it and that's
not really going to solve any of this
and i'm really about solutions that's my
driving force in life at this point and
i think there are actual solutions and i
thought that clip which of course that
was jordan peterson uh ben shapiro and
myself that was reuben report back in
2018 sort of at the peak of the whole
idw thing and i thought what jordan was
talking about there
was something that you're just not going
to see on mainstream media like
something having to do with
responsibility and what really drives
people and the desire for attention and
perhaps a plague that is
affecting young people right now in a
new way maybe because of social media
and the rest of it so that's sort of how
i want to frame the show today and
in contrast to what we did yesterday
where it was really apolitical i felt we
needed just a day to be apolitical today
i'm going to have to get somewhat
political because some of the responses
especially by some mainstream
well-known democrats were just
absolutely horrific and it's not that
you want to endlessly focus on them but
you do want to expose them so that you
know what the bad ideas are and then
hopefully you can then find the good
ideas
from that so basically we'll be covering
a little bit about the shooting itself
and what happened
the left's response a little some of my
feelings some of the positive answers i
mean that's really where i'm going to
try to get us to
at the end of the show today oh and just
real quick i want to thank everyone for
the comments especially the locals
community yesterday you know it really
was a different show than than we've
ever done yesterday hopefully we'll not
have to do too many shows like that um
but i was in the comments all day
reading a lot of stuff and my guys were
sending me particularly uh nice things
uh and and thoughtful comments and that
a lot of you were feeling exactly what i
was feeling like we can't just be
screaming about politics right now we
can't this can't just be about policy
and all of it there's something else
going on here right there's some sort of
spiritual crisis going on here there's
something going on within all of us that
then leaks out into society and that's
what we should be addressing and we'll
get to more on that in just a sec real
quick guys i want to talk to you about
fast growing trees because i'm doing
some landscaping and trees are part of
it you know spring and summer are the
seasons for finally getting outdoors for
entertaining pool parties and bbqs but
if your yard looks like a plant cemetery
you're not going to enjoy it as much get
your place looking like a resort easy
and fast with fast growing trees when it
comes to caring for your plants know-how
matters that's why fastgrowingtrees.com
experts curate thousands of plant
varieties that will thrive in your
specific climate location and needs
there's no waiting in lines and no messy
cars from hauling your plants all over
town because you order online and over
the phone and your plants are shipped to
your door in one to two days plus their
growing and care advice is available 24
7 whether you're looking for increased
privacy shade or adding some natural
beauty to your yard
fast growing trees have the perfect
plants and expertise to help you find
them even if you've never had a green
thumb they'll make you feel like you do
one million home gardeners have already
seen what fastgrowingtrees.com can do
for them i've got some orange trees in
my backyard right now plus with their 30
day alive and thrive guarantee you can
trust that everything will be healthy
for years to come go to
fastgrowingtrees.com reuben right now
and you'll get 15 off your entire order
get 15 off at fastgrowingtrees.com
reuben fastgrowingtrees.com reuben and
now back to me okay so first let's just
do the the 101 on the of all day
shooting uh and i want to focus on these
kids more than anything else so let's
just do the sobering part of what
happened and as i said yesterday
because i'm trying to do this in in
somewhat of a nonpartisan way we all
have our own biases obviously
but particularly yesterday i was trying
to do this without politics i'm even
sourcing the quote that i'm going to
read from the new york times
from not a paper that i generally
respect just to give you the facts here
so from the new york times a gunman
killed at least 19 children and two
adults on tuesday in a rural texas
elementary school a state police
official said in the deadliest american
school shooting since the massacre at
sandy hook elementary a decade ago the
gunman whom the authorities identified
as an 18 year old man who had attended a
nearby high school was armed with
several weapons officials said he also
died at the scene they said so more
importantly than getting into any
further part of the nitty-gritty or
really anything about the shooter and
i'll address in a moment why we
shouldn't be focused on the shooter
specifically the individual specifically
i just want to show you an image of some
of the victims
those are 19 kids
they're about five to seven years old
mostly eight nine i think i think
there's a couple that are 10 years old
so there are those kids they went to
school two days ago
their parents sent them off to school
packed them lunch and
they are gone
and we can all scream about all the
reasons why they're gone and we can
place blame on all sorts of people
i blame the person who did it i blame
some of the societal forces around that
uh but just put the image up one more
time i mean i just think it's important
for people to just get these these are
just kids these are kids like you have
kids or you have nieces and nephews or
you were once a kid
these were lives that existed on this
planet
two days ago that do not
exist anymore
there is a bit more about the shooter i
don't want to go into too much about him
uh but this tweet
uh from jeep hollowitz on twitter uh we
blanked out the shooter's name and i'll
discuss a little bit more on that uh
blank reportedly cut his own face shot
people at night with a bb gun and was
known to police over fights with his mom
now the reason i'm mentioning that tweet
is because the fact is he was on law
enforcement's radar he also shot his
grandmother he had had fights with his
mother as you can see
that there clearly was a mental health
issue here so one of the themes that
you're going to be hearing about
over the next couple weeks obviously is
we just need more laws we just need more
laws more strict laws we just have to
take guns away all of these things
and the simple fact is law enforcement
knew about him in almost every shooting
that we're hearing about now law
enforcement usually has met with the
person or has been alerted about the
person these systems are not perfect now
we can talk about how to tighten these
systems we can talk about how to do a
better job with law enforcement but the
simple answer seems to always be oh just
give us more laws if we just had more
laws around guns if we just had more
laws around bad people and generally bad
people do bad things whether there are
laws or not now one of the main reasons
that i'm not covering uh the the
shooter's name
is because i don't want these people to
have any more notoriety i think this is
a key thing this is something that the
mainstream media is completely missing
and years ago we should have all stopped
saying their names i actually stopped
saying their names a couple years ago on
the show and it was in large part
from this conversation that i had with
jordan peterson and ben shapiro this is
a further clip from the cold open that
we just showed you a few minutes ago
think about the people who do highness
crimes like the the school shooters
people like that who do these things
that are almost inconceivable a huge
part of the drive for that is fantasies
about notoriety and and and and and the
emergence from obscurity and anonymity
even though it's it's notorious it's
hatred
the idea is i'd rather be dead and
infamous than alive and anonymous which
by the way you i think were one of the
first websites to say we're not going to
publish these people yeah they're
they've been
their names escape me but there are
other people who have been promoting
this for a while but yeah i was late to
it we should have done it earlier and i
talked to the canadian broadcasting
corporation about that about 10 years
ago about the idea that publicizing the
names of these killers is precisely one
of the mechanisms that ensures that it
will continue to happen
peterson i just love the guy that line
i'd rather be dead and infamous than
alive and anonymous
and there's something about the whole
that is perhaps within all of us right
now and maybe social media really
exacerbated it maybe it really enlarged
that thing
that people want fame they want
attention more than anything else that
this thing that was supposed to make us
social that it it did something to make
us all feel more alone right it was
supposed to connect us that was the
thing and then we got left in this world
where we feel more worthless
we have to think about that because that
has something to do with all of this
so for that reason right there
i am not going to say the shooter's name
i would hope that some other
organizations i know the daily wire is
not going to do it i'll actually talk to
my friends at the blaze and see what
their policy is on this but they are
going to keep saying his name over and
over on mainstream media and that just
sort of adds to it because then there's
another kid out there who's dealing with
some of the same issues that this kid
was dealing with and they think oh i can
be somebody too
i can be somebody too and the internet
has then so disconnected them from
reality they would rather have that dead
and infamous than alive and anonymous
thing so we're just not going to do it
uh okay so now on to some of the
political
side of this what we could be doing
is really talking about the deep
psychological issues behind this we
could be talking about the mental health
stuff we could be talking about families
we could be talking about communities we
could be talking about the social media
element of all of this but as i said
everyone's just diving into their
political
uh it's not even their agendas they're
diving into their political
full belief systems and and fame seeking
and all of the worst kind of stuff the
worst one i saw yesterday uh was beto
o'rourke now you know better o'rourke he
is a media superstar who's never really
accomplished anything he ran for senate
in texas against ted cruz and
fortunately lost now he's running for
governor in texas he's not doing that
well because texas doesn't like a lot of
his uh his really blue state sort of
democrat policies um he showed up at the
press conference that governor greg
abbott was giving with the mayor of
uvalde the police chief and a bunch of
other people ted cruz was there he
showed up and well he made it all about
him
excuse me
excuse me
excuse me
you're out of you're out of line and an
embarrassment
[Music]
i'm sure you are out of line please
leave this auditorium
i can't believe you're a sick son of a
[ __ ] that would come to a deal like
this to make a political issue
yeah you want me to come in
federal o'rourke is a horrible human
being i don't know how to describe it
any other way like
that he made this about him that he made
this about politics these kids are not
buried yet
there you have the mayor of the town you
have the governor of the state you have
the senator you have the police chief
they are talking about what happened
they are trying to figure out what can
be done
and he dare gets up
this has nothing to do with him but he's
running for governor and he wants
attention and he got a lot of retweets
yesterday and he got a lot of coverage
on msnbc and cnn and i'm sure in the new
york times and washington post he got
exactly what he wants because the media
seems to reward the worst of us
the gentleman who said sir you're out of
line that is the mayor of uvalde okay so
that is the man most responsible for the
families who just lost their kids so he
was making his feelings very clear about
this the guy who called him a sick son
of a [ __ ] uh is the sheriff
okay
uh
beto o'rourke is an embarrassment is it
he's an absolute embarrassment he is the
type of person that should have nothing
to do with politics go be an actor dude
go be some attention
[ __ ] fame seeking whatever but do not
be a politician nobody well i can't say
nobody likes you in texas there's a
certain amount of people i suppose that
like you in texas but go move to
california
and take all their guns if that's what
you want to do but but putting aside the
politics of this that you dare get up
there in the middle of this as these
people are grieving i mean it's just
absolutely extraordinary and now if you
want to see a politician doing the right
thing
doing the right thing so there's uh
texas governor greg abbott
and he was sitting there amongst all of
those people and he responded directly
to beto
there are family members
they're family members
who are crying as we speak
their family members
whose hearts are broken
there's no words that anybody shouting
can come up here and do anything
to heal those broken hearts
we all
every texan
every american
has a responsibility
where we need to focus not on ourselves
and our agendas we need to focus on the
healing and hope
that we can provide to those who have
suffered unconscionable
damage to their lives and loss of life
we need all texans
to in this one moment in time
put aside personal agendas think of
somebody other than ourselves think
about the people who were hurt
and help those who have been hurt
which one of those guys do you think is
right the guy who gets up there who has
no place being at that press conference
or certainly breaking into the press
conference to start to scream and make
it all about him and basically blame
those people because they have a
different policy when it comes to guns
than he has
or the governor there who did not make
it about politics who made it about the
people who had just been killed now
we can have an honest debate again as i
said yesterday and i'll continue to say
for a long time about most of our
political things we can have an honest
debate about guns
and the second amendment
and whether we should have guns and all
of those things now obviously i believe
in the second amendment
i bought guns for the first time in the
last two years after everything that
happened um but that's a that's a policy
disagreement right like one side
believes that having guns is the best
thing that will protect you because you
can protect yourself a school can
protect itself you'll have the ability
to protect your family the other side
believes i i personally believe it's a
mistaken belief that if only the
government could take away enough guns
that their that bad things in essence
wouldn't happen now that's a mistaken
belief but i'm willing to have that
debate i find people on the right always
willing to have that debate what people
on the left generally seem to want to do
is do exactly
what beto o'rourke did there which is oh
you guys are bad guys it's your policies
that led to this etc etc there is no
evidence that it was their policies that
led to this okay there just wasn't and
again
we never talk about what happens in
chicago and i think we covered it
yesterday it was 46 people were shot in
chicago over the weekend six were killed
but that doesn't really fit the
narrative for these people because of
the skin color thing doesn't quite work
and chicago has the most stringent gun
laws in
the entire country so we can have an
honest discussion about this i see one
side roughly trying to do it and another
side that's not doing it all we've got
plenty more examples that we're going to
show you in the next couple minutes real
quick guys i want to talk to you about
real estate agents i trust you know
buying or selling a home is already one
of the most stressful things you can do
and it can be 10 times worse if you're
not working with the right agent agent
generally speaking our homes are our
biggest investment that's a lot of
responsibility and you need an agent who
takes that seriously that's why i
recommend real estate agents i trust we
work with only the best agents in every
market we do our homework talking to
every agent before inviting them to join
our network and here's a big one we only
work with full-time professionals no
part-time or inexperienced agents our
team makes the intro and then follows
you through the buying or selling
process to make sure that you're
satisfied the agents we work with have a
long track record and are the best
sellers in their field they're part of
this audience they share your values and
they're almost anywhere you want to go
the process is simple just go to real
estate agents itrust.com and provide
them with some basic info our team will
contact you to make an intro to the
preferred agent in your town the company
was started by my friend glenn beck and
i know a lot of you are looking to move
to florida so think about it real estate
agents itrust.com
okay so let's move on to some of the
other reaction because as i said even
though we don't only want to focus
on the negative on the people who go
purely to politics we have to understand
it right like this is the give the devil
his do thing see what the people who who
really are wrong who use everything for
their own
purposes see what they're saying because
if you really see it and you and you
understand where they're coming from
then maybe you can respond to it
properly so there were i mean we could
have spent literally 10 hours today i
could have spent i could have spent 24
hours today just reading you horrific
tweets and facebook posts and instagram
messages from politicians and blue check
people the worst sort of responses
saying that republicans have blood on
their hand i mean just the most vile you
know
that you know certain politicians are
murderers are just the worst worst worst
sort of stuff um we could have done that
but we're only going to select a few
here uh here is squad member progressive
and marxist communist socialist
ilhan omar from minneapolis minnesota
who destroyed that uh city and state by
the way uh she's responding to a tweet
here's a guy by the name of perry stein
and it's a quote two uvalde police
officers and a school resource officer
fired at the shooter but it did not stop
him from entering the building and then
he links to a washington post article
the point being that there were some
officers there and they were not able to
stop this there are some questions as to
whether they did everything they could
do etc etc connor can we throw up her
tweet again so i can get to that
she retweeted it and responded honestly
every republican who said this is how
you stop mass shootings need to be voted
out of office they're pro-gun agenda is
dangerous and it's time for sensible gun
reform laws in american enough okay so
first off this thing about sensible gun
law reforms okay it means nothing what
they usually say is common sense
gun law reforms
common sense i mean we have background
checks right we have checks on people's
mental health you cannot create a
perfect system you cannot do it there
are always going to be people who slip
through the cracks there's always going
to be someone who buys a gun legally and
then someone who's able to get that gun
that maybe lives in their house and
finds the key or whatever it might be
they're also a crazy
crazy amount of illegal guns in cities
like chicago
that are murdering people every single
weekend find out if most of those guns
or that are killing people in chicago
are legally bought or illegally bought
they're usually illegally bought which
goes to show you that no matter how many
laws you have bad people will get
bad things pull up her tweet sorry one
more time on the tweet so their pro-gun
agenda is dangerous and time and time
for sensible gun reform laws in america
the pro-gun agenda is an interesting way
of putting this thing what she should be
saying is the pro-second amendment that
you have the right to defend yourself
and perhaps if this school
had had other policies if this talented
at other policies texas texas has pretty
good gun policies but perhaps everyone
watching this wherever your kids go to
school whatever synagogue you go to or
church you go to or community group that
you go to if they thought about things a
little bit differently why is it that
there are armed guards outside of barack
obama's house why are there armed guards
outside of the u.s capitol building why
are there armed guards
virtually everywhere where politicians
exist right we suddenly we can find
money for that but we can't find money
to put armed guards or a local community
member who is armed it doesn't have to
be some outsourced thing it could
hopefully maybe it's a father a retired
police officer in the community etc etc
that could guard these schools and do
better
defense of these schools rather than
taking away people's god-given rights
which is really what the push will now
be i mean the push obviously now by the
left is going to be republicans they're
they're of course they're racists and
nazis but they're also murderers and we
should take their guns away and thank
god we have the second amendment and
thank god we have the first amendment
which is defended by the second
amendment so we can say what we think
and we can still
defend ourselves and then if there are
little marginal places to talk about
what we can do around some of the gun
laws and by the way i bought a gun in
california it was incredibly hard and
took an extremely long time is it easier
to buy a gun in texas yes it is and
perhaps should we look at some of the
ancillary things around that perhaps we
should but that's not really what this
is about um
by the way then joe biden gave his
talk the night of the shooting and i
thought about playing it yesterday but
again i was trying to go a political
yesterday
his speech was one of the most
disgusting speeches i've ever heard by a
politician i mean if if beto o'rourke
and his little outburst and he's just
sort of a a furry clown let's just
forget beto o'rourke hopefully he'll
just be a little footnote in history joe
biden had a moment where he could have
really tried to bring the country
together really tried hey guys we have
differences when it comes to policies
we have differences when it comes to
what our first what our bill of rights
says and how we analyze these things and
we we view things differently and we
have different values there was a moment
he could have done that and we could we
can put all that aside today so we can
mourn for these kids but he couldn't he
went purely political in the most vile
way there were awful lot of videos we
could have chosen from
here's one and we must ask when in god's
name will we do what needs to be done
to not completely stop fundamentally
change the amount of the carnage that
goes on in this country
to state the obvious
corey and a lot of other people here i'm
sick and tired
i'm just sick and tired
of what's going on it continues to go on
i spent my career
as chairman of the judiciary committee
and as vice president working for common
sense gun reforms
as i said as a senator and vice
president while they clearly will not
prevent every tragedy
we know certain ones will have
significant impact and have no
negative impact on the second amendment
second amendment is not absolute when it
was passed you couldn't own
a
you couldn't own a cannon
you couldn't own certain kinds of
weapons
it's just always been limitations
but guess what these actions we've taken
before they've saved lives
it's just so much nonsense all he does
is put together words and usually not
say them in the right order or
particularly well and of course those
aren't his words those are words that
are written for him again he says the
common-sense gun law thing it just is an
irrelevant statement common sense well
people have different definitions of
what common sense is i am sure that my
definition of common sense is quite
different than joe biden's definition of
common sense but putting that aside just
the way he made it about politics and
he's really sick of this and he spent
his whole life trying to fight this
stuff well obviously he didn't do a very
good job of it in his 47 years in the
senate or however many years it was he
was also vice president for eight years
didn't get much done then but now
somehow he's going to do it and what he
means is by common sense
what he means is my common sense my
common sense to take away your guns and
this thing about oh but back then you
couldn't have a cannon so there were
always limitations first off there are
limitations and we leave it usually up
to the state what those limitations are
um but this idea that you couldn't have
a cannon back then also the government
didn't have the crazy weapons that it
has right now and there is something in
that bill of rights about a well-armed
militia because it keeps the government
at bay it keeps the government at bay we
know that okay that's why not always the
guy with the biggest gun wins
right i mean think of most insurgencies
vietnam war perhaps the guys with the
biggest bombs uh didn't necessarily win
and the bet the best weapons they didn't
necessarily win um he also says do what
needs to be done
which by the way is a line that
palpatine said to darth vader when he
went in and slaughtered the younglings
he says we have to do what needs to be
done
well okay that sounds like something but
once again it's just hollow words do
what needs to be done
we disagree on what needs to be done
that's the problem you think what needs
to be done is take away more weapons
make more people reliant on the state
take away the ability for people to
defend themselves how about guys is this
nuts i got a crazy one
how about uh we just gave ukraine 40
billion dollars we don't have 40 billion
dollars but we just gave it to ukraine
i'm pretty sure we could have taken that
40 million that we don't have but we can
always find it for other people's wars
we could have perhaps taken that and put
an armed guard at every school or had a
true analysis of what's going on at each
school or actually i wouldn't do any of
that through the federal government i
would cede that money to the states and
the local municipalities and have them
figure out what their real policies are
related to this perhaps we could have
better training when it comes to the
officers that are there because as i
said earlier it turns out that some of
the officers didn't do whatever it is
they were supposed to do
but there are no perfect answers here
but these glib statements they're really
i mean this is what democrats are
incredibly good at these glib statements
we must do what must be done we must
have common sense meaningless drivel
that's what it is but joe biden
continued on twitter and of course it's
not him tweeting he said it's time for
those who obstruct or delay or block
common sense gun laws we need to let you
know that we will not forget
we can do so much more we have to do
more now again all he means there is we
must take more guns and again common
sense no he note there's no specifics
there's no specifics it's just common
sense what we should do is common sense
we don't have to tell you exactly what
it is it's common sense and then
barack obama got in this now barack of
course was joe biden's boss for eight
years obviously did not do a very good
job at anything uh because if he did
then joe biden wouldn't have to be
president right now and donald trump
would have never been president but a
lot of people were pissed after eight
years of obama but obama did i mean i'm
going to show you this twitter thread
the worst
sort of making everything political and
really read this does this strike you as
a good man who is trying to heal what's
going on in this country heal the thing
that we're all feeling
or is this someone who purely wants
political powers it's disgusting
actually here's obama as we grieve the
children of uvalde today we should take
time to recognize that two years have
passed since the murder of george floyd
under the knee of a police officer his
killing stays with us all to this day
especially those who loved him
in the aftermath of his murder a new
generation of activists rose up to
channel their anguish into organized
action launching a movement to raise
awareness of systemic racism and the
need for criminal justice and police
reform
then he continued inspired by these
young leaders mbk alliance launched a
reimagining policing pledge for mayors
and cities ready to take action if
you're wondering how you can get how you
can help to make things a little better
today here are some ways to get involved
i mean this is absolutely incredible
what he did there first off this
shooting has absolutely nothing
nothing nothing nothing to do with
george floyd but obama come by he's a
politician more than anything else we
thought he was hope and change and he
turned out to be something very very
different he is nothing other than a
paper bag politician who is taking the
murder of 19 dead kids to somehow try to
combine it into something that has to do
with george floyd and of course he says
systemic racism and systemic racism is a
phrase much like common sense gun laws
which just sort of means nothing no one
denies that there is racism but there
are no racist laws in the united states
also he forgets you know he talks about
the two years of protests and things
that we had yeah that's right there were
uh an awful lot of you guys remember
them when we lived in la the destruction
that was everywhere all the destroyed
stores all the signs that were put up on
all the stores that said i'm for blm and
peace and tolerance and they put those
signs up so that their stores wouldn't
be destroyed by the peaceful tolerant
people and they still burned them down
anyway and broke all their windows and
the rest of it
so obama
man
the greatest shyster of all time perhaps
hope and change was this the hope and
change you now combine
the murder these kids are not even
buried yet you freak
and you dare combine this basically with
blm and antifa who destroyed who gave us
two years of mass violence
two years of mass violence like vile
absolutely vile then there was another
one
this one man i you know what by by later
by tomorrow we're getting back to some
funny stuff okay that's my commitment to
you guys but we have to do this when we
have to do it we have to do it to make
some sense of the world uh here's a
tweet by a guy by the name of rick lewis
and he found uh one of the fathers of
who was mourning his child
okay this guy the picture that you're
seeing there i don't even care about who
this rick lewis person is doesn't matter
uh but the person you're seeing there is
a father who just lost one of his
children
this this blue check oh no sorry he's
not blue check he's got a blue heart but
this person on twitter found
this guy's who just lost his kid found
some of his previous social media posts
and found out that he was for the second
amendment and he was uh for kyle
rittenhouse and he went after him he
said the father of one of the victims
from the texas shooting was pro-gun and
literally championing kyle rittenhouse
on facebook and this is and then of
course you know it's like man the guy's
child just died that tweet went very
viral so i'm not even making it about
this random person on twitter it's
because they find anything to make it
political it's theater
it is theater instead of offering a
little bit of sympathy for someone whose
child just died i cannot imagine
anything worse in the human experience
it's oh he's four guns
and what that is is a difference of
political opinion
the father believes that you should be
able to defend yourself i suspect he
still does right now and i would suspect
i didn't want to talk about it but i
would suspect
that he probably feels as if the school
had done a better job defending itself
that this would have never happened but
now is not the time to discuss that but
the theatrics just continue the
theatrics just continue here is
connecticut senator chris murphy
he's a democrat of course
and just watch this theater 101
political performative experience why
why are we here
if not to try to make sure that fewer
schools and fewer communities go
through what sandy hook has gone through
what uvalde is going through our heart
is breaking for these families
every ounce of love and thoughts and
prayers we can send
we are sending
but i'm here on this floor
to beg
to literally get down on my hands and
knees and beg my colleagues
find a path forward here
work with us
to find a way
to pass laws that make this less likely
you know it's funny he said he was on
his hands and knees didn't get on his
hands and knees which if you're going to
act you know i took acting class for a
couple weeks around 2004
you got to go all in that's the thing
with acting but he did not get on his
hands and knees he also did not pray
let's not pretend for a second that that
guy prayed for these families but what
does he need what does he need you to do
in his performative theatrical
ridiculousness he needs more laws
he needs more laws there are dead kids
and and his response of course is more
laws
his response is not hey what what is
happening in society that would lead
people to do horrific things
unimaginably horrific things that's what
we should be talking about the jordan
peterson clip that's what we should be
talking about why are people doing bad
things if i had an ar-15 right here and
everyone's freaking out about ar-15s
right now if i had an ar-15 sitting next
to me right now would i walk into a
school or anywhere else and shoot anyone
obviously not
some people would so is the issue the
ar-15 or is the issue the person who
holds it and the societal
and and existential and psychological
forces that
condition someone to do that you
obviously know the answer uh well then
here's a tweet from meteorite jen sake
remember her remember jen saki well what
happens when there's a shooting you put
the former press secretary who has lied
about everything more than anyone else
over the last two years who of course
just stepped down and she's now doing
the press circuit because she's got a
new show on msnbc where she can continue
to lie so she goes on jimmy fallon the
late night show which is supposed to
make you laugh before bed thankfully no
one watches these shows anymore and of
course she gets to talk about how if we
could just you know get rid of more guns
then everything will be okay right she
wants us to jerk people awake and what
she means again by that this is all they
mean with all of that is to take away
your constitutionally guaranteed rights
that's what they mean
and they continue
man these people are just
they're just they're just so bad they're
so so bad i'm sorry we have to show you
so many of them but don't worry at the
end we're giving you some hope uh here
is eric swalwell who is a congressman
from california um he has slept by the
way with a chinese spy that is a fact
that is a fact eric swalwell slept with
a chinese spy
but nobody really talks about that
that's okay uh here he is uh blaming
republicans instead of blaming the
person who did the shooting but right
now the truth is not by a policy defect
but by design by design of the
republican party in this country every
kid in every classroom is exposed and
vulnerable to a shooting and no police
officer outside the classroom as we have
seen is going to protect them uh no idea
that you know more good guys with guns
in the community is going to protect
them and no sense of you know let's just
throw money at mental health is going to
protect them
horrible human horrible human men he's
right up there rebedo and obama they are
just horrible human beings instead of
what are the real issues well first off
i'll give you a little credit there
you're right not just throwing money at
things doesn't do things that's
interesting to hear a democrat saying
that because that's all you guys do you
just throw money at things so you think
inherently oh we threw more money at
something it must work i agree that
throwing money at mental health things
doesn't just fix things as i said
yesterday i lived in la where there were
always signs everywhere for los angeles
mental health call this number and the
idea that the los angeles department of
mental health was making anyone more
sane or helping anyone is is that's
actually insane so throwing money at
things is not the answer but when he
belittles the idea that if you have
police officers or armed guards outside
of things that a good guy with a gun
can't stop a bad guy without with a gun
that's in that's completely wrong there
are many many instances of good guys
with guns doing more now we can we can
figure out ways to better defend the
schools right we can do that he doesn't
want to talk about that what he wants to
do is flatly blame the republicans the
republicans who are the one party right
now who are going to still defend your
second amendment rights your
constitutionally guaranteed rights now
the democrats don't they're not for the
constitution right they think that this
thing is fundamentally evil this country
and it was founded on racism and these
documents were written by old racist
white men but we have one party that's
willing to defend those rights and maybe
does it sloppily and not very well all
the time and one party that wants to
come to them so he's blaming his
political opponents for this as opposed
to blaming whatever is going on here
collectively in our psychology that is
allowing people to do this here's a
really interesting moment from cnn
yesterday uh jake tapper who i often
talk about he's he's pretty bad but he's
not like cnn level bad all the time and
he sometimes kind of gets it he's
obviously a democrat you know pretending
to be neutral where he isn't
he has some ability to show some
humanity through some of it and he tried
to do
tried to ask um this police chief who
was on an apolitical question watch how
quickly this became
political it's incredible cnn senior law
enforcement analyst former philadelphia
police commissioner and former chief of
police here in washington dc um chief
ramsey thanks for joining us um
first of all i know you're a dad what's
your reaction not as a law enforcement
official but
as a dad when you hear stories like this
well i'm a grandfather now so i mean you
know you hear things like this i got a
granddaughter who is about to begin
kindergarten so
i mean obviously this is something that
we should not even be talking about i
mean this is absolutely crazy and what's
even crazier is the fact that nothing's
going to be done about it absolutely
nothing you know i listen to the
governor of texas as the same governor
that was very proud to sign the
legislation that he says is protecting
the unborn well what about the kids that
are already here governor what what are
you going to do to protect them what
about the 14 we lost today what about
the 20 we lost to sandy hook i mean when
is this going to end instead of all this
chess pounding about you know they're
passing this legislation you know to to
protect the unborn and we do nothing to
protect the ones that are already here
the worst sort of everything is about
politics you can possibly get the
question was about oh you have kids how
do you feel about this he then says he
has grandkids and then the whole thing
is about abortion
right it's about abortion and the answer
when he's saying well absolutely nothing
will be done again what he's saying
absolutely nothing to be done
the subtext of that is i want something
to be done meaning i want to take away
guns as if again as if that really is
the problem if the real problem is just
if we took away
guns and that is not the problem it's
not so we get this constant sort of
bipolar mostly dishonest take from
almost everyone in the media but okay
what do i always try to do on the show i
try to give you something rational i try
to give you something tangible to take
with you and there are
some rational uh there are rational data
points and there are rational answers so
first i want to go back to
texas governor greg abbott who obviously
is right in the middle of this thing
right now he is the governor of the
state that is thought of when you think
about guns in america you think about
texas more than anything else and this
this horrific
i don't even want to say tragedy this
horrific murder it's not a tragedy a
tragedy is somewhat accidental this is
an intentional
horrific murder mass murder by this uh
18 year old uh is happening in a
happened in a city in his state so to
bring this thing full circle what are
some of the answers well i thought greg
abbott did a pretty nice job right here
i know people like to try to
oversimplify this
let's talk about some real facts
and and that is
there are quote
real
gun laws
in chicago
there are quote real
gun laws in new york there are real
gun laws in california
i hate to say this but
there are more people who were shot
every weekend
in chicago
than there are
in schools in texas
and we need to realize that that people
who think that well maybe we just
implement
tougher gun laws
it's going to solve it
chicago and l.a and new york disprove
that thesis
okay
so that's honest that's real
right the places with more stringent gun
laws have more
gun
deaths someone explained chicago to me
if you are watching this and you think
i'm a bad dude and i'm mean and i'm
lying about any of this stuff and you
want to explain to me what's going on in
chicago which has the strictest
gun laws in the nation
as a city in illinois
uh again 46 people were shot this past
weekend that's a couple days ago six
fatally doesn't make the news doesn't
make the news then you have to think
about why and as abbott is rightly
saying as i've said repeatedly
throughout this
if you just had more laws none of this
would happen if we just took away more
guns none of this would happen yeah
you're right in chicago they could take
more guns away and guess what all the
bad guys would have the guns all the bad
guys would have the gun so i thought a
nice way to sort of recap this whole
show
uh would also be to give you some
specific numbers about guns from pew
okay so pew polling pew research
they're reputable i very few people i
think are doubting whether pew is doing
a good job or not when it comes to
giving us some sensible honest numbers
so this is an important part of the show
so when you're debating with someone and
they're telling you
all of this stuff and all of the deaths
and all of the confusion about all of
this you'll have some actual numbers to
go to so here's some direct data from
pew research in 2020 54
of all gun related deaths
in the u.s were suicides while 43 were
murders according to the cdc now just
sit with that for just a second
more than half of the gun deaths were
suicides okay so then you have to sort
of remove them from this mass shooting
conversation okay now again that's
clearly more of a mental health
issue than anything else but let's go
back the gun violence archive an online
database of gun violence incidents in
the united states defines mass shootings
as incidents incidents in which four or
more people are shot even if no one was
killed again excluding the shooters
using this definition
513 people died in these incidents in
2020 regardless of the definition being
used fatalities in mass shooting
incidents in the u.s account for a small
fraction of all gun murders that occur
nationwide each year in 2020 handguns
were involved in 59
of the 13 620 u.s gun murders and
non-negligent manslaughters for which
data is available according to the fbi
rifles the category that includes guns
sometimes referred to as assault weapons
were involved in just three percent of
firearm murders that's a key part of
this whole thing shotguns were involved
in one percent the remainder of gun
homicides and non-negligent
manslaughters 36 percent involved other
kinds of firearms or those
classified as type not stated okay so do
you understand this a huge percentage
over half of the gun deaths are suicides
okay so that clearly is a mental health
issue and how these people are getting
guns we can discuss that okay fine right
and there's no perfect system so even if
you have mental health background checks
because you have background checks
everywhere every state has them
including texas are there some people
that are going to slip through the
cracks are there some people who are
going to be able to answer questions and
have a clean background check and and
fake it and then actually they turn out
to have mental health issues of course
there are are there people who are going
to develop mental health issues after
they have the gun of course so again
this is one of those things we are
imperfect we cannot create perfect
systems um but the rest of the that
information that i just laid out there
is pretty fascinating three percent
three percent right let's pull that up
again because that's that's the key part
on that uh three percent um were assault
weapons but they're really going after
the assault weapons right now now again
we can have some conversation about that
we really can and you know there's
always this thing well you don't need an
assault weapon to shoot a deer that's
true you don't
um
we can have some conversation about that
but the implication is that somehow
we're having mass mass shootings and
it's all being done with these things
and it's a small percentage of the
murders with guns and
it's a small percentage using those
weapons in the first place so what can
we do
what can we actually do well i thought
this was an interesting image that i saw
posted by john rich on twitter this is
posted at a school in ohio this is
outside the school building attention
by authorization of the rhlsd
superintendent that's the local
school board rock hill local school
district staff is trained and armed any
attempt to harm children or staff will
be met with whatever force is necessary
to protect our students so they have
armed staff at the school they have a
warning about it i suspect that they
have people who are local members of the
community who are doing just that right
you're not just paying someone sort of
you know minimum wage or whatever it
might be to sort of stand there and
maybe put their life on the line or not
but it's about you
taking your life your children's life
the teachers the administrators their
life seriously and it's about doing it
at the local level the federal
government is not going to come in and
protect all 350 million people of this
country the data that i just laid out
there from pew
which is indisputable is proving that
this is not a gun problem it is a people
problem it is a mental health problem
and if we are willing to have that
conversation
then perhaps we can clean up some of
this and in a more broad sense if you
have a people problem if you have a
mental health problem instead of just
creating laws to manage those people how
about we think about something else so
now to bring this whole show full circle
i want to go back to that conversation
that i had
with ben shapiro and with jordan
peterson
ben talked about the crisis of meaning
that we have in america and what that
leads to
and i think that part of the resistance
to particularly i think jordan but i
think also to me and to anyone else in
the idw who's at least searching for
meaning is that the left has been saying
for a long time that we found the
meaning right the meaning was do what
you want to do the meaning was no
responsibility do what you want to do
that's the meaning the meaning is
rebelling against the system and when it
turns out that a lot of people don't
find meaning in that that there is in my
perspective a god-shaped hole in
people's heart that is being filled by
hatred and polarization and tribalism
that god shaped whole right
the idea that nietzsche said god is dead
and it was a warning that if you take
out the structure that exists that
everyone sort of believes in to whatever
degree they believe in it you completely
remove that
people are gonna start believing all
sorts of other things right the need for
belief is so fundamentally important
that people will start believing in
other things people will start believing
that boys or girls and two plus two is
five and non-racists or racists and the
rest of it and maybe that
is far more of what really is going on
here than oh if we could just have the
law to stop this there's something else
going on with all of us and then when it
is hyper fueled by this thing
do you think that maybe is causing a
problem and when you find out that the
powers that be can manipulate us to see
certain things and not see certain
things and lie about certain things and
all of that do you think that adds up to
a situation where a young person growing
up in a very confused world without a
lot of good role models without
a system that rewards people for doing
the right thing and instead rewards
people for usually doing the wrong thing
um do you think that that could lead to
a whole bunch of stuff i think it could
i think it could uh we're not going to
do any comments uh today we do have a
cold close from jordan in just a second
but in 10 minutes from now wow this was
this was a long show uh in 10 minutes
from now we're this week's q a which i
normally source all the questions from
the locals community at
rubinreport.locals.com we're going to do
a q a exclusively on locals so anyone
can watch people have already put in
their questions
reubenreport.locals.com you can download
the ios app or we have a android app at
google play store or you can just go to
reubenreport.locals.com
on your desktop and the q a will be
streamed right there so i hope you will
join us and i hope you'll consider
joining uh where you can then submit
questions and interact with everybody
else and all that good stuff okay i hope
the rest of the week is a little more
humorous than
what it's been uh for this week but this
this is the point of everything you
can't you can't have what you want at
all times there's there's a messy world
out there we gotta do our best to clean
it up and i think that's a perfect segue
here for jordan peterson and our cold
clothes
you know what it's like you get engaged
in something a deep conversation a piece
of music a piece of art something you
love doing someone you love being with
you get engaged in that you lose your
sense of temporality and you don't pop
out of it and think oh my god i wish i
would use the time frame that made
everything irrelevant because of my you
know cognitive brilliance you think hey
we could do that some more like how
about all the time
and that's that's a good goal it's like
yeah how about that all the time
and then you've got time right when
you're engaged like that and i would say
that's a profound neurophysiological
signal that you're in the right place at
the right time right because it's
accompanied by a sense of deep
well-being and that's literally an
antidote to suffering i mean that
literally it's
with many of my clients who were
suffering
what we would strive to do was not so
much
make them happy because sometimes that
was impossible they were so
crippled in in so many ways often
physically and in pain
but something meaningful
that would keep them going
and keep them from straying
and keep them from thinking
homicidal and genocidal thoughts all of
that and meaning that's the antidote to
suffering and the question is well how's
that best to be found well that's an
empirical question you have to you have
to look in your own life and see where
meaning glimmers and then pursue that
you